vanessa and the late kobe bryant's
daughters
17-year-old natalia three-year-old
bianca and one-year-old capri joined
forces with sabrina ianescu
to shake it up on tick-tock
thunderball but let's be real
this dance party didn't start until
little miss bianca
popped up on the video oh my god oh my
god
and look at that eye roll girl knows
she's cute
the ladies were dancing and clapping
their hands to sean paul's temperature
sabrina captioned the cute clip salt
shaking saturdays with my girls
the wnba rookie who is mentored by kobe
has spent a lot of time with the bryant
family sabrina shared this
instagram video with vanessa over the
weekend both
struggling to get out of bianca's pink
range rover
at one point capri walked over while the
ladies continued to crack up over their
antics
but it was this video that made
headlines
in june sabrina and natalya were showing
off their moves on tick-tock and were
joined by bibi
who adorably popped up right in front of
the camera and stole the show
once again
the three-year-old was dancing with her
fist up rocking a bright yellow
sweatshirt and the
cutest smile
in the end the two besties couldn't help
but bust up
in laughter sabrina captioned it another
bb special appearance